it was the all-american boy handsome
smart charming
in fact Theodore Robert Bundy was the
stereotype of what every American boy
ought to be like and what every American
parents wanted their son to aspire to
above all Ted Bundy was charming he had
a winsome way that could entrace people
yet this same college wunderkind snuffed
out of the lives of scores of beautiful
young women he was a charismatic killer
who's Jekyll and Hyde personas were so
vastly different that he fooled his
closest associates for years many of
them would still not believe that their
Ted could commit the atrocious crimes
that were piling up alongside his name
even as the evidence became overwhelming
he made a mockery of law enforcement
running rings around their attempts to
catch the world's first serial killer
Bundy's brilliant minds made him a
master predator with his abductions
being as well-planned as a military
action
he has gone down as the most infamous
serial killer in US history today
decades after his execution in the
electric chair he is held up by many as
a macabre celebrity the poster boy for
mass murder his story is a paradox in
his past there were no signs of the
deviant behavior that would manifest
itself in an insatiable bloodlust he was
in fact on track for a brilliant career
on the other side of the law as
prosecuting attorney his performance in
his own defense showed what great
promise that career had held upon
sentencing Bundy to die Judge Edward o
coward summed up the feeling of so many
that knew and were affected by Bundy it
is a total waste of humanity that I have
ever experienced in this court you are a
bright young man you'd have made a good
lawyer I'd have loved to have had you
practice in front of me but he went
another way partner as we examine
Bundy's story we got closer to answering
the question of why he chose the way he
did but then again even with this
analysis we may never really know just
before you get started with the
biographic Svidler if you like this sort
of darker stuff definitely check out
friends of the channel there's another
channel called criminally listed go
check it out you'll find a link to it in
the description below
loads of darker stuff like this on that
channel and let's get into it
[Music]
Theodore Robert Bundy was born to 22
year old Ellen Lewis Cowell on November
the 24th 1946 his father was a sailor
who've never hung around to meet his
newborn son when he was four Ted's
mother who he was told was his older
sister took him 3,000 miles away to
Tacoma Washington to live with other
family members
Ted was heartbroken to be taken away
from his grandfather with whom he had
developed a special bond
although no one ever replaced his
grandfather in his affection Ted soon
became close friends with his two
cousins Jane and Alan Scott meanwhile
his mother was making a French of her
own
Eleanor was now going by the name of
Louise she joins the Methodist Church
and soon crossed paths with a young man
by the name of Johnny Culpepper Bundy
Johnny Bundy stood only five foot tall
he was a cook and came across as a shy
and reserved kind of guy but Louise
sensed that he was kind and dependable
soon a romance and blossoms after a well
winds of Methodist social functions
Louise and Johnny were married on May
the 19th 1951 the family bought a home
near narrows bridge while Johnny kept on
working as a cook Louise turns her heads
to secretarial work children followed
two boys and two girls as he grew up Ted
was often pressed into babysitting
service he willingly complied even
though it would usually mean missing out
on outings with friends although the
family dynamics were stable ted was to
grow up in an environment of untruths
and uncertainty he was still being fed
the line that his mother was his sister
and that his grandparents were his
actual parents during his years at high
school he ran with kids who had
connections whose parents were either
rich or were bigwigs in the school
environment Ted could never match up and
as a result he was often teased where
others were outgoing Ted came across as
shy and reserved Ted never warmed up to
his father-in-law
despite Johnny's acceptance of him and
attempts to build a relationship when
Johnny became a scout leader and
organized camping trips Ted would
usually find some excuse as to why you
could under tennis in adolescence Ted
grew rapidly but he found it very hard
to put on muscular size he was too
skinny to play football that we did join
the track team that hunts junior high
however it was a classroom rather than
track and field where Ted felt most
comfortable he maintained the average
taking his schoolwork and homework very
seriously
Ted graduated from Woodrow Wilson High
School in 1965 while he was making solid
progress academically he was also
beginning to build a reputation
that was not so favorable he had already
been in trouble with the law in relation
to some petty burglaries it was also
proving himself to be an unreliable
worker after graduating high school
Ted began working for Tacoma City Light
his plan was to attend college and he
enrolled in the University of Puget
Sound for the 1965 to 1966 year 12
months later he transferred to the
University of Washington in Seattle he
began living on campus at a dormitory
room at McMahon Hall at the University
of Washington
Ted's winning personality began to
manifest itself he was charming
well-dressed and came across as educated
his professors thought he was a
brilliant studious individual with
enormous potential deads charm and good
looks may people see beyond the
emptiness there was at his core it was
during his freshman year at Washington u
the Ted first fell in love the object of
his desires was a beautiful dark-haired
girl that lived nearby she was as he
would later describe her the most
beautiful creature he had ever seen he
found out her name was Stephanie Brooks
from a distance
Ted admired her studying her like a
specimen under a microscope he stared at
her in the lunchroom fantasizing from
afar it seemed became apparent that
Stephanie was into the football jock
crowd and Ted became despondent despite
their differences there was one thing
that Ted and Stephanie had in common
they were both skiers Ted thought that
maybe this was his in showing signs of
overcoming his insecurities he took the
bold step of asking if he could hitch
with her to the ski slopes east of
Seattle she readily agreed happy to have
some company and thus this began the
start of their unlikely romance the bear
started spending more time together
Stephanie seemed to enjoy his company
and sort him out as for Ted he had
become besotted with Stephanie soon they
were lovers Stephanie was 21 Ted 20 she
was from wealthy California stock he was
a legitimist she grew up in the midst of
money he didn't have anything yet their
relationship worked and they went steady
for the next year for Stephanie the year
with Ted was an enjoyable extended fling
she was in love with him sure but not in
the way that he was with her she had
known from the start the relationship
was never really going anywhere that
spend some time together enjoy
themselves and then go their separate
ways after all there was no way that Ted
could ever fit into her society the
Stephanie's graduation in June 1968
seems like the opportune time to end the
romance she'd be moving to
francisco to find work while ted stayed
on in seattle to finish his studies to
say that ted took the rejection from
stephanie badly could be the ultimate
understatement he was absolutely
devastated crime author and rule who
worked with ted on a seattle crisis
hotline leaves that the breakup of his
relationship with stephanie was the
catalyst for everything that followed in
Ted's life ted could not accept that the
relationship was over he immediately set
about finding ways to weave stephanie
back he also immersed himself in law and
politics as if to drown out the agony of
losing her Ted's despondency spreads to
his academic life the once brilliant
student was now struggling by the fall
of 1968 here two dropped out completely
after several months wallowing in
despair here Ian rolled at the
University of Washington taking papers
in psychology that included deviance
personality and deviant development
throwing himself into his studies he
impressed his professors as an honor
student who was truly gifted
despite his rigorous study schedule Ted
still found time to frequent the bars of
the University District in September
1969 the handsome affable young man
called the eye of a woman named Meg
Anders
they were both alone at the Sandpiper
Tavern Ted made the first move asking if
he could buy her a beer reluctant at
first she was soon won over by the Ted
Bundy charm before she knew it she had
given him her phone number
Ted and Megan began spending evenings
together and Megan quickly came under
Ted's spell falling deeply in love with
him in a sense this was a reversal of
Ted's relationship with Stephanie meg
adored the ground that Ted walked on yet
it was less committed his mind often on
other things and other people he was
still pining for Stephanie but Meg would
do in the meantime 1969 and 1970 were
stable years in the life of Ted Bundy he
was focused on his academic progress
impressing his professors and gaining
qualifications that would lead to his
chosen legal career the relationship
with Meg was steady and he was playing
the part of surrogate father to her
young daughter LeAnn and he did this
with passion and joy during 1970 Ted was
awarded a commendation by the Seattle
Police Department
when he ran down a purse-snatcher a few
months later he saved a drowning toddler
at Green Lake Ted had pretty much
transformed herself into the
all-american boy now at the beginning of
1971 Ted took a part-time job at the
Seattle crisis clinic situated on
Seattle's Capitol Hill he did the 9:00
p.m. to 9:00 a.m. shift a few nights a
week on a Tuesday night between 10:00
p.m. and 2:00 a.m. he was partnered with
thirty nine-year-old part-time crime
writer named Ann rule for ten months
they work together the crime writer
and the future serial killer they worked
tirelessly to help solve people's
problems
on many occasions they even helped save
people's lives Ted was an amazing
counselor he was always calm and he had
an aura to his voice to put people at
ease he reassured he guided and he
entertains and empathetically listens in
April of 1973 Ted was awarded the
position of Assistant to Ross Davis
chairman of the Washington State
Republican Party along with the job came
a $100 per month salary use of a credit
card and expenses for travel were paid
by this time
Ted's had been with Meg for four years
their relationship it was steady
although it often felt like Meg was
doing more of the giving than Ted was
still he was excellent with little
Leanne who absolutely adored him
marriage seemed just over the horizon
for the couple what Meg didn't know was
that Ted still carried an unquenchable
desire for Stephanie Brooks even when he
and Meg were making love it was
Stephanie's image that was present in
Ted's mind and so it was that when he
flew to San Francisco on a Republican
party business trip in the summer of
1973 he looked her up Ted and Stephanie
they went out for dinner she was bowled
over by the changes he had made now he
was sophisticated he was confident he
was in control and it appeared he had
money Ted's plan to win her over works
perfectly and on parting she agreed to
come and see him in Seattle and she did
just that
during our autumn vacation Ted took
Stephanie to dinner at the home of his
boss Ross Davis he introduced her as his
fiancee then he whisked her off for a
weekend in the snow at Cascade Pass he
had booked a luxurious condo for just
the two of them over the course of that
weekend Stephanie fell in love with Ted
all over again when he began talking of
marriage plans
she excitedly joined in future plans for
a life of domestic bliss were made of
course neither Stephanie nor Meg knew of
the others plans to marry Ted Bundy
after his weekend with Stephanie however
he began to evade talk of marriage with
Meg he seemed to be getting very cold
feet towards the end of 1973 Ted managed
to coordinate his two love lives so that
he could wine and dine Stephanie more
liberally he brought her to Seattle and
they dined at various restaurants
throughout Chinatown strangely though
stephanie was sensing that something was
different Ted was becoming less
affectionate he stopped talking about
marriage plans he confessed that he had
been having an affair with another
women and the cheered ended up having an
abortion he was becoming cold clinical
and uncaring towards Stephanie
he didn't even buy her a Christmas
present despite her attempts to get to
the bottom of his strange change in
attitude stephanie was unable to
discover why Ted had become so cold to
water he simply wouldn't let her in when
she flew back to San Francisco at the
start of the new year
Ted appeared to be glad to be getting
rid of her Stephanie waited for Ted to
reach out for an explanation as to why
he had turned but it never came in
February of 1974 she phones him angrily
demanding an explanation he simply hung
up on her and without Stephanie would
never again speak to Ted during the
first six months of 1974 eight women
went missing from college campuses in
Washington Oregon and Utah when you look
at the photos of these women you can't
help but be struck by how much they
looked alike they all had small friends
long hair that was parted in the middle
and were good-looking every one of them
resembled Stephanie Brooks as the case
files mounted the killer left no trace
investigators were surprised and
immensely frustrated that a man could
commit such brazen abductions and leave
absolutely no trace of evidence in his
wake indeed each attack would be
slightly more brazen than the last the
adapter would snatch girls who were in
closer proximity to others almost as if
he was daring anyone to stop him
located at the southern end of Lake
Sammamish in King County Washington Lake
Sammamish State Park covers 512 acres
and features six thousand eight hundred
and fifty eight feet of waterfront the
level landscape features butter cup
filled pastures and is dotted with trees
in the summer of 1974 it was a popular
bathing spot and sunning spot for
thousands of local residents lifeguards
patrolled and there was a Rangers heart
on sight on July the 14th of 1974 Lake
Sammamish was packed with in excess of
40,000 people who were eager to make the
most of the glorious summer weather
among the throngs of Sun seekers on
their day was an attractive woman who
was sunbathing by herself on the beach
no sooner had she settled into a tanning
session than she looked up to see a man
towering over her he was wearing a white
t-shirt and jeans and his right arm was
in a cast excuse me I'm sorry to bother
you he began I was wondering if you
could help me out the girl looked over
at him he was good-looking and seemed
somewhat nerdy to her she didn't sense
any danger from him help you out with
what she asked he then knelt down beside
her and explained that he needed to
launch his sailboat but couldn't do it
with his cast on he offered to take her
for a ride in the boats and he was
exceedingly charming yes she would go
with him she said as they were walking
to where the man said his sailboat was
he offered his name Ted it was about
this time that the girl got cold feet
she begged off saying that her parents
were waiting for her two other young
women at the lake that day they weren't
so lucky
23 year olds Janis artined 18 year olds
Denise Naslund went along with Ted's and
we're never seen again Ted had
dramatically upped the stakes not only
had he freely given his name to a
potential victim but it approached at
least six women on that Sunday afternoon
in broad daylight
clearly he was feeling invincible there
was nothing that the bundling
law-enforcement officials could do to
stop him he was far too clever for the
police they were able to produce a
composite sketch of Ted based on the
statements of the eyewitnesses this was
circulated up and down the country 3,500
tips poured in from the public the
police compiled a list of potential
suspects named Ted Bundy's name was on
that list but it had more than 2000
people on it
Ted moved to Salt Lake City on
Thanksgiving weekend 1974 to attend law
school he immediately secured job as a
security guard at the University the
initial focus of the Utah killings was
one of the small towns that lay within
the vicinity of Salt Lake City
they began on October the 2nd 1974 the
victim was 16 year old Nancy Wilcox she
disappeared from holiday a small town
just out of Salt Lake City Nancy had
walked to the store to buy some gun and
she was last seen by an eyewitness
getting into a light brown Volkswagen
bug Ted's next struck on October the
18th this time the victim was the
daughter of the Midvale police chief
Lewis Smith the 3rd Utah victim was 17
year old Laura Amy from late 25 miles
south of Salt Lake City it was October
the 31st Halloween night Laura was a
high school dropout who had moved out of
her home in him with her friends bored
at the lack of action that night she had
left a local cafe just after midnight
and proceeded to walk to a local park
she was never seen again less than a
month later Ted abducted an 18 year old
girl from a local mall by impersonating
a police officer fortunately she managed
to break free from his car moments after
he had slapped handcuffs on one of her
wrists a frustrated Ted drove for
another 17 miles before coming to view
Mons High School where a school
production was in progress he abducted
and killed 17 year old Debbie Kent in
1975 though Ted found a new killing zone
Colorado
it appears he murdered at least five
women during a six-month period burying
their skulls in a bizarre graveyard in
the Taylor Mountains in the early
morning hours of August the 16 4 1975
the police finally caught up with Ted
Bundy a minor traffic violation led to a
search of his car which produced a
burglars kit complete with handcuffs and
rope the authorities were scene able to
connect the dots and charges of
aggravated kidnapping and criminal
assault were brought against him he was
found guilty and sentenced to 115 years
for the police this was just the start
they now set about building a case to
hold Bundy accountable for the trail of
bodies that had left in his wake Ted was
adamant that he would defend himself in
the upcoming trial and was given access
to the Aspen law library to do research
during a visit at the Law Library on
June the 17th 1976 Bundy managed to slip
out of a second-story window he went
straight for the local River Bank he
took off his courtroom outfit to reveal
a second set of clothes underneath he
brushed himself off and calmly walked
back to the center of town as the police
rushed to set up roadblocks he wild away
his time browsing in stores it was
classic Bundy after a week on the run he
was recaptured I need to break out again
six months later this time he was able
to evade recapture and set out for
Florida he set himself up in the
vicinity of Florida State University for
over a year he managed to control his
urges until on the night of January the
14th of 1978 his demons were unleashed
in an orgy of violence that left two
girls dead and two more horribly beaten
at the Chi Omega sorority house over the
following weeks
Ted continued his rampage killing a
14-year old girl and attempting to
abduct another the girl the daughter of
a police detective helps police produce
an identikit picture and that along with
a series of mistakes on Ted's part led
to his recapture around February the
15th 1978 this time there would be no
escape after a lengthy trial in which he
defended himself Ted Bundy was found
guilty of murder and sentenced to death
in the electric chair he spent a decade
appealing the decision that was finally
executed On January the 24th 1989 by
that time the Bundy phenomenon grown
with a legion of mainly female fans who
had fallen in love with Ted and wrote
passionate love letters to him it seems
that they conveniently forgot that he
was one of the most cold-hearted killers
in history so I'm not gonna ask whether
you enjoyed the video definitely one of
our darker ones but if you did find it
interesting please give it a thumbs up
below also if you're looking for more
great content like this there's another
channel I'd like to recommend they're
friends of this channel end of top tens
as well they're called criminally listed
you can find a link to them in the
description below so go check them out
also see some of our videos from the
archive over there on the right and as
always thank you for watching
you